jetzt fragen wir sie und das löst eine
gewaltige diskussionen gerade wieder
deutschland aus lassen sie sich ein
viertes mal impfen in diesem herbst
corona impfen ja oder nein ein top promi
dieser corona krise sagt für sich jetzt
ganz klar nein zur vierten impfung ja
und zwar eher virologe hendrik strick
und damit stößt er eine ganz neue große
impf debatte in deutschland an
hendrik strikt ob virologie er ist einer
der wichtigsten köpfe der korona krise
seit fast zwei jahren mitglied des
expertenrates der bundesregierung also
einer der wichtigsten berater des
gesundheitsministers auch zum thema
impfen hendrik strikt jetzt sagt er für
sich nein zu einer weiteren vierten
corona impfung strikt zu bild ich werde
mich diesen herbst nicht wieder gegen
korona impfen lassen ein satz der eine
neue diskussion auslöst direkt vor einem
möglichen neuen corona herbst vierte
impfung ja oder nein karl lauterbach er
hat sich vier mal impfen lassen und
empfiehlt diese vierte impfung längst
vierte impfung top virologisch trieb
begründet bei bild warum er für sich
dagegen ist weil ich inzwischen dreimal
gm wurde und im sommer einmal infiziert
war so der mediziner von der uni bonn
und weiter erklärt strebt eine vierte
impfung wäre für mich aber auch nicht
nötig hätte ich keine infektion gehabt
und das auch dann wenn die
infektionszahlen im herbst und winter
wieder stark ansteigen sollten sein ko
ohne schlupf reiche wie für millionen
andere deutsche inzwischen völlig aus
die neue große impf diskussion in
deutschland vierte impfung ja oder nein
top virologisch trick hat für sich die
antwort darauf gefunden ein klares nein
[Musik]